[Music]
man just hearing that song gets me
excited and in just three days and sync
will reunite when they get their star on
the Hollywood Walk of Fame but that's
not the only surprise they have in store
for their diehard fast only et online
lauren zima was with JC shows a giving
us a sneak peek at their dirty pop-up
shop this one is something that Justin
wore Cobra reveal dangerous some of us
keep more than others Joey happens to be
a pack rat some of the stuff is just all
fresh never seen before you had one
outfit that you're like me why did I
worry about so what can we expect from
JC Justin Timberlake Lance Bass Joey
Fatone and Chris Kirkpatrick at Monday's
Walk of Fame ceremony when we perform
will you wear matching outfits we agreed
on dressy casual and what about a
reunion tour I look there are no talks
about a reunion tour right now you get
like cool merch for right now and then
you know the future is what it is of
course et's been with the band since the
beginning and how about this for a
little flashback Friday 1998 before N
Sync hit a big they were doing a bus
tour on the streets of New York Justin
Lance Joey
Chris JC I was still going through
puberty in my 20s it deal
one back a couple blocks ago I'm gonna
go back after we do this thing and ask
her if she wants to go out he's missing
the one asking the girls out more than
everybody else I wouldn't put the flirt
on him if anything I'd probably put the
flirt on Joey
Oh Joey he's a hoarder and a flirt I'm a
mess and thanks dirty pop-up shop we'll
be in Hollywood until it's gonna bei May
first
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]